the incessant spread of the coronavirus
has brought in its wake yet more
local lockdowns middlesbrough along with
the liverpool city region
warrington and hartlepool are now on the
list
over one-third of the uk population is
living under creeping social
restrictions
we recommend against all social mixing
between people
in different households we will bring in
regulations
as we have in the northeast to prevent
in law
social mixing between people in
different households in all settings
except outdoor public spaces like parks
and outdoor hospitality but that drew a
furious response from the mayor of
middlesbrough
obviously if there is a law i will
follow the law and nobody
should break the law but as things stand
i do not accept these proposals they are
unnecessary they go too far they'll
damage mental health
and they'll kill viable jobs the
epidemic's explosive growth
since the start of september has been
revealed by new research
one in 800 people had the virus across
england in the first half of the month
by the start of this week it was four
times as common
affecting one in every 200 people
worryingly the virus is spreading to
more vulnerable groups
with infection rates in the over 65s
increasing by
seven times over the month but tests
done
since the start of the rule of six
suggests the spread of the virus
may be slowing with the r number
reducing from 1.7
to 1.1 as we change our behavior
there was a wake-up call to be honest at
the beginning of september because
although the virus was at low levels and
that's what we reported at that time
the rate of increase was was high and
that did send
alarm bells ringing and i think people
have got the message
more the second wave is playing out very
differently to the first
in the spring the virus was evenly
spread across england
but after lockdown was eased the virus
bounced back
more quickly in some areas perhaps
because there were more residual
infections
and higher deprivation rates creating a
striking north-south divide
we know that deprivation is considered
it considers many factors
it considers housing it considers
density of population
it considers inherent health it
considers whether you have risk factors
for things like
whether it be heart disease they could
be stroke for example
all the various factors have the
potential to increase the amount that
you would see covet 19 infection in
those populations
for now this has the look of a two-speed
epidemic
increasing faster in some areas such as
middlesbrough
but the rest of the country isn't off
the hook relax the social distancing
and the virus quickly takes advantage
thomas more sky news